the problem with Glencore is that this
is a company that was 80% trading 20%
hard assets until 2012 right at the top
of the cycle
they bought Xstrata changed the face of
the company completely so that they're
now 80 percent hard assets 20 percent
trading and the whole idea was was if
there was a downturn in the commodities
markets the trading acumen would help
offset the hard assets it didn't work
that way the trading at the traders were
long the same commodities the mining
assets were and so I you know if that
was the the reason to put this thing
together one has to question that
strategy and if you look before that
2012 deal
Glencore was earning double digits on
its capital it was a trading house that
was basically a good trader now they're
earning low single digits on their
capital it's changed business a lot I
mean you and shortly exactly let's just
say I'm a potential purchaser you're a
potential purchaser I'll let you think
about that for a second potential
purchaser of what well you have to close
out a short position you have to buy
stock right the moves are making now
they're selling copper mines back in
there so they were buying assets at the
top of the market right and now the
commodities have crashed they're selling
assets so it sounds smart to you but do
they but do you think that I mean zinc
they cut way back on right on Friday and
there was indication in the markets as I
recall the terminal indicated that
really the price was going up on saying
right don't you think that they aren't
the commodities prices they're getting
rid of the asset and that makes the
price go up they don't they don't
benefit from that right right that's the
problem and so again it's I'm concerned
about a company that's supposed to have
this great trading acumen that seems to
be buying things at the top of the
market and selling them at the bottom
those just doesn't sound smart to me and
so I think until 2012 you'd be
hard-pressed to find them doing anything
that wasn't smart I mean there was an
extraordinary company like yes what
you've laid out makes the argument
they've left their core competency they
jump the shark trading is what they do
and they've left that but this is really
a big mistake but
first mistake we've seen out of them so
they did very very well in a bull Marcus
what you're saying okay and when the
markets turned bad they did not so well
and I mean I think that that at the end
of the day that's the issue is was this
just simply a play on rising commodity
prices as opposed to a company that made
lots of money in both good and bad
markets and I think that the certainly
we can question that